Politics now. A sitting U.S.
senator who has already been criticized
for racism
has suddenly taken up the cause seemingly
of white nationalists
being able to serve in the U.S. military.
In a radio interview
this week, Republican Senator
Tommy Tuberville of Alabama
had quite the flaming hot take
Democrats are attacking our military,
so we need to get out
the white extremists,
the white nationalists, people
that don't don't believe
in our agenda as as his Joe Biden agenda.
You mentioned the Biden administration
trying to prevent
white nationalists
from being in the military.
Do you believe they should allow
white nationalists in the military?
Well, they call them that.
I call them American now.
On first
blush, Senator,
Tom Perriello seems to be taking up
the cause of white nationalists,
people, people
who believe in
building a white centric state.
And he seems to be arguing
they deserve to be armed and trained
and to serve in the U.S. military.
TUBERVILLE
His office has since attempted
something of a cleanup effort.
Releasing a statement to Alabama RT.com
saying, quote,
Senator Tom
reveals, quote, that incited cited shows
that he was being skeptical of the notion
that there are white
nationalists in the military,
not that he believes
they should be in the military,
unquote, today.
Tuberville
talked to CNN off camera
and said, quote, Here's the problem.
Democrats portray
all MAGA Republicans
as white nationalists. That's not true.
We got a lot of great people
in the military that are MAGA
is that's what I was talking
about, unquote.
All right.
Let's break this down three points first.
No one
no one in the military is worried
about MAGA.
Republicans serving in the U.S. military.
That would be ludicrous
for any number of reasons,
especially given the fact
that so many service members
are conservative.
Point
to obviously most service
members do not fit the definition.
But there is a white supremacist problem
in the U.S. military.
According to the U.S.
military, in study after study.
And there's a long list
of actual incidents
and domestic terrorists
who fall into this category.
Point three
Senator Tom Carville's
attempt to distance himself
from seeming
to be
standing up
for the rights of white supremacists
might be easier to believe
If last fall, Senator Tuberville
had not made one of the most
blatantly racist statements
we've heard from a U.S.
senator in perhaps decades, He
falsely suggested
that Democrats like crime
and he smeared black people as criminals.
Take a listen.
Some people say, well,
they're soft on crime.
No, they're not soft on crime.
They're program they want crime.
They want crime
because they want to take over
what you got.
They want to control what you have.
They want reparation
because I think the people that do
the crime are owed that bullshit.
They're not owed that
Senator Tom Real.
They're saying that Democrats like crime
and they want reparations,
which is the term for
payments made to individuals
who are descendants of slaves
because they think that people
that do the crime are owed that.
That's just racism.
Tuberville
not only defending the right of racists
to serve in uniform, he's actively
keeping right now
high ranking
military officials
and officers out of uniform.
Senator Tuberville
is currently protesting
new Pentagon policies
implemented in the military
that provide leave for troops
or their families
who need to travel to get an abortion
because they are in a state
where it is not permitted.
There are currently 196
military nominations
pending in the Senate.
Generals, admirals,
600 for I'm sorry, 60 for three
in four star positions.
That will need to be filled soon,
including the chief
of the staff of the Army,
the director of the
National Security Agency,
commander of U.S.
Cyber Command,
Defense Secretary Lloyd Austin.
This week,
calling it
a major national security risk,
blasted Tuberville
in a letter writing, quote,
Without these leaders in place,
the US military will incur an unnecessary
and unprecedented degree of risk.
At a moment
when our adversaries may seek
to test our resolve, unquote.
This also,
of course,
has a trickle down effect
on other military officer nominations,
which in turn impacts
regular military service members
and their families
who are moving to new installations
for new assignments.
The guy doing this, the guy
holding up all these generals
and admirals
and colonels from being promoted
and from the military
for being ready for whatever
threats the US faces. Senator Tom.
To sum up,
he says, black people are criminals.
He says white nationalists are Americans.
And I guess
for Senator Tuberville, the year is 1843.
Let's talk about this
with former Republican
Congressman Adam Kinzinger.
Who served in the U.S.
Air Force, currently serves
as lieutenant colonel in the Air
National Guard. A lot to talk about here.
Let's start
with his comments
on white nationalists in the military
And this idea that
the Biden administration wants to purge.
I mean, I'm
not sure
whether he is actually defending the idea
of white nationalists
serving in the military
or he is lying about the fact
that there's
some effort
to get Republicans out of the military.
I think he's lying about both.
You know,
first off,
there are some things I disagree with
that are happening in the military
as a pilot.
You know,
I spend quite a bit of my time
doing computer
based training on things
that have nothing to do with my job.
You can criticize that
and you can't make that an issue.
Yeah, but the idea
the idea that there are white
nationalists is wrong.
There's some it's not a lot,
but there's some.
And then, you know, the idea
that they're Americans is is is crazy.
You would just say,
oh, they're Americans.
They're fine.
And the idea that there's
this push to push out
Republicans is not true either.
You know, the U.S.
military is one of the last institutions
to enjoy bipartisan support.
I mean, even the FBI
now is a partizan thing.
Every person that tries
to make the military a partizan issue.
Ted Cruz,
you know, tweeting
about how great the Russians
are despite
the fact
that they're
getting crushed on the battlefield now
you know, that kind of stuff.
It's politicizing the military
and that can't happen.
And white nationalists, by the way, Jake,
should be excluded
from serving in the U.S. military.
I got to ask when I joined the military,
if I was a communist
or if I was a member of a group
that sought to overthrow the U.S.
government and a fighter said yes,
I wouldn't have been able to serve.
We can expand that to include
white nationalism.
And I mean, it's for me,
this comment about like,
well, I call them Americans like that
coming after what he said
about Democrats like crime.
And that's why
they want to give reparations
to the people who do the crime.
I can't
recall a more blatantly racist statement
by a member of the U.S.
Senate in literally in decades.
Yeah.
And the problem
is, Jake,
we're kind of like numb to the outrage.
And now there's so much outrage
that is just constantly
being thrown at us
that it gets buried or we're like,
oh, that's that's not a huge deal.
That's a huge deal.
I mean, it's
it's outright blatant racism,
what he said.
I'm glad.
I guess he's trying to change
what he meant by that.
I don't think it's inaccurate.
The changes,
but at least he's, you know,
recognizing that that's bad for him.
But here's what happens.
You know,
everybody has a battle in their heart
every day between light and dark.
You know,
and when leaders stand up in front of you
and they speak
the dark parts of your hearts, the fears,
you know, all that kind of stuff.
It gives permission for that darkness.
To overtake you.
And leaders
in America, for the most part,
you know,
for all of our history
have realized they have to
they have to shed light.
This is a time where they're standing
in front of crowds and spewing darkness.
And it's a frightening time, frankly.
It is.
We heard some of that darkness
last night also.
Former Congressman Adam Kinzinger,
thank you so much, as always.